it's more important than ever for teams
to take ownership of the reliability of
their services this is especially true
in distributed environments like an
e-commerce website that depends on
services like inventory Shopping Cart
and notifications today we'll look at
how to use the data from a service mesh
to understand traffic error rates and
Layton sees in micro service
applications with stackdriver
this is the stack dr. developers use
micro services to architect for
portability scale and decoupling this
presents some challenges with operations
and management you have to manage all of
the various services and understand the
interactions between them this is where
a service mesh comes in let's take a
look at how a service mesh and stack
driver can work together to help us
understand what's going on in a
distributed application to start we need
services we'll use this application it's
a web store that sells really cool
products it also happens to be composed
of a number of micro services written in
a variety of languages you can take a
look at it for yourself in this github
repository in a complex environment like
this how can we go about measuring
reliability this is where a service mesh
is going to help us but first what is a
service mesh according to the sta open
source project a service mesh is used to
describe the network of micro services
that make up distributed applications
and the interactions between them the
real value of a service mesh like sto is
that it enhances the security
reliability and observability of
services sure not necessarily easy to do
in kubernetes without it what does that
mean for us
well let's take a look at what happens
when we have our micro services
application managed by a service mesh
first let's create a gke cluster with
ISTE already installed on it here's the
command we'll use to create the cluster
and enable STL on it
this will automatically set up the
stackdriver adaptor to send metrics logs
and traces to stackdriver
now that the cluster is up and running
let's deploy our micro services
application here are all the services
that have creates these services are
instrumented with the proxy sidecar the
proxies send telemetry information to a
component called mixer which in turn
sends
the stackdriver let's go there and see
what new information is available we'll
start in the metrics Explorer if we
search for sto we'll see all of the new
metrics that are created by his geo for
all of the services in the mesh the
first thing we want to do is to
configure alerting using these metrics
so that we can find out if any of our
services have issues with performance or
availability first let's create in the
learning policy for front-end latency
we'll use the server response latency
metric filtering by destination service
name for just our front-end and further
filter our response code to just measure
latency for successful requests now
let's create another alerting policy for
our front-end availability this time
we'll use the server request count
metric we'll also filter it by
destination service name for the
front-end and then further filter it to
only count responses that do not return
a success and there we go now we're
using information from the service mesh
to let us know when our front-end
services experiences a degradation and
either latency or availability but what
happens when we do get an alert that
there's an issue and our service is
degraded the problem has to do with
latency we want to start by looking at
tracing well the good news is that the
stack driver adapter in the service mesh
is not just sending metric data it's
also exporting traces wouldn't need to
do anything to instrument our code the
service mesh trees is service to service
calls for us and sends the data stack
driver on the other hand if the problem
has to do with availability or errors we
would want to have easy access to
debugging information like logs the
service mesh is also exporting logs the
stack driver we can look at kubernetes
container locks with a proxy for example
to see a record of all requests there
are any issues we need to debug this can
be a great source of information so
thanks to the data being exported by the
service master stackdriver
we've configured alerting and service
availability and performance looked at
latency with traces and dog into logs
come back next time when we look at
improving observability even further
with custom metrics that's it for this
episode this is the stack dr. stay
healthy out there
you
[Music]